so when you are freaking out and you're
seeing some real Horrors in here who do
you talk to to unstress you have a
shrink
no I sort of talked to everyone and
people fill different needs for me there
is no one person Howard but also I'm
more fundamental as a person especially
the older I get who's going to help you
with the problem that 700 people died
yesterday
no I'm willing no one can help have you
cried during this you have yes yes
at what point I can't get over the death
numbers every day I can't and I can't
rationalize it and the health care
workers have been heroic and have done
great work and we saved every life that
we could because the health care workers
were great I can't get past the death
numbers there's nothing that abates that
pain are you drinking at all not a drop
since this started Wow
nothing not a beer not a beer oh no I'm
not gonna be in a compromised this is 24
hours a day and I'm not gonna be in a
compromised position
remember that age where you have a
couple of glasses of wine you feel it
the next day
that's right and I'm not going to be
diminished now I wouldn't do that thing
Thank You governor your selflessness yep
yep Robin's hitting the sauce very
heavily but look is there anything we
can help you with that's what I want I
know you have linear time so I don't
want to run out without saying that I
mean you you know I don't know what the
number-one problem is right now for you
but is there anything we can help you
with you know how would your voice
Robins voice is so important
we're fighting a virus we're also
fighting emotions people are frightened
people are anxious they're stressed it's
unprecedented you're at home you're
trapped you're afraid to touch another
human being you're not getting a
paycheck the communication is as
important as anything else
yeah I'm fighting the virus but more I'm
fighting stress and anxiety and distrust
and depression so we are going to get
through this
the God's honest truth there we are
going to get through this thank you
that's all I'm gonna say thank you
that's it